the name is bond chanter bond
olivine eggnog shaken not started
classic brosnan
ah
michael my car my car
extreme my car back r this is parkour
internet sensation of 2004 and it was in
one of the bond films it's pretty
impressive the goal is to get from point
a to point b as creatively as possible
so technically they are doing parkour as
long as point a is dilution and point b
is the hospital
[Applause]
okay
jump over the camera jump over the
camera
okay we all go together or we go one at
a time here it is here it is uh truck to
refrigerators to dumpster 360 spin onto
the palace backflip gainer into the
trash can yeah yeah yeah yeah
hardcore parkour
i'm right behind you come on
yeah
i figured out the best way to welcome
pimento to the nine-nine stay out of his
way maybe buy him a drink
not do anything weird i'm making him a
goat stew huh all right yeah
now this turkmenistani dish is
traditionally made from an animal that's
been so overfed it can no longer stand
that's a dream everything is authentic i
even ordered the pressure cooker from
turkmenistan so you're on a terrorist
watch list now oh yeah homeland
security's been at my house yep now this
just needs to cook for another 11 hours
32 minutes and six
what the hell boy you almost killed me
i'm not going out in a stool making
accident terry's gonna die saving the
president or jerry's never gonna die
hey derek
what a defeat man i mean i did not
expect to win by that much but i warned
you i'm a good bowler whatever all
joking aside i want to say that i
actually had fun and i'm really looking
forward to your vote in the spring yeah
i'll just write in [ __ ]
i'm sorry what did you just say just
ignore him he's being a jerk i said
she's a [ __ ]
oh my god what the hell i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry that was awesome i'm so
sorry
oh look oh here's that photo if you
wanted
ow sorry
party plannings are real high like a
runner's high
hmm
have you reviewed the contents of
gordon's computer did you find anything
uh well
ham ha
are you literally saying hammond hawk
look i haven't found anything okay not a
single email between kelly and gordon so
i hoard myself out of that museum for
nothing not entirely for nothing you
know we had fun sneaking around bribing
people lying stealing stuff coming home
and having my husband ask me why i
smelled like barrels seriously what'd
you say i told him everything he
understood until i showed him a picture
of gordon the thought of me at a museum
with that ten he banished me to the
guest room captain holt are you in there
oh no it's him what does he want do you
think he knows something happened at the
barrel museum i wanted to talk to you
about something that happened at the
barrel museum i think he knows this is
bad well the longer we talk the more
suspicious it seems tell him to come in
come in
oh i'd prefer to discuss this matter in
private anything you have to say to me
you can say in front of peralta very
well i've been sent here to spy on you
what i am truly shocked we are both
shocked commissioner kelly knows you're
recruiting a team of captains to oppose
him he asked me to find out who they are
but i've decided i won't help him why
not because i've fallen in love with you
what
that is truly shocking for real this
time what
the plan was for me to weaken your
defenses with my brazen sexuality i
wouldn't say brazen so much is
completely undetectable i couldn't have
been more obvious i wore a single
windsor knot i might as well have a
signer on my neck that reads dtf
desiring thorough fornication no exactly
oh at first the flirting was just part
of the ruse it meant nothing to me but
then the barrel museum
i fell hard not surprising it is an
erotically charged atmosphere the curve
of the slats the rivets the bilge the
bunghole okay i am actually starting to
hear the sex talk now the bungle is the
least erotic part of the barrel it's
simply functional sure sure sure
bunghole continue captain i know nothing
could ever happen between us but i care
about you too much to do kelly's dirty
work which is why i'm tendering my
resignation that's very honorable i
accept no no you don't this could be our
chance we could turn kelly's agent into
a double agent operation double dragon
oh it's all starting to happen i don't
want to play these movie spy games
peralta it could backfire or it could
front fire what it worked gordon do you
have any hard proof that kelly sent you
here nothing in writing we only
communicate in person okay so you call
kelly arrange for a meeting then you
wear a wire and we have tape of the
commissioner admitting that he's spying
on one of his captains it could work but
i can never put gordon in that position
i would do anything for you captain holt
thank you and you can call me raymond
captain raymond holt i don't think
that's such a good idea you're right too
much
that should never have happened agreed
wait what did something just happen i've
been standing here the whole time what
did i miss
what did i miss what did i miss
uh oh okay okay nobody panic listen up
listen up
everyone follow me to the shelter we've
got enough food for 14 days
after that we have a difficult
conversation my bad space heater and fan
were both on high plugged into the same
outlet so
uh it's saying the server went down
does anybody know that password because
otherwise we can't do any work oh try
password
nope try zero zero zero zero zero zero
no okay now try zero zero zero zero zero
one okay i'm not doing every number wait
um does anyone remember when it was set
up uh
it was like eight years ago lord of the
rings
stuff i don't know i'm just trying to
think of things that were happening at
the time um everyone was getting their
driver's license
why don't we just call the it guy who
set it up
what's the name of the guy in the
glasses okay moving backwards our i.t
guys have been glasses turban ear hair
fatty three shorts fatty two lozenge and
fatso i think lozenge is the one who
installed it i got it try um
you know what it made me laugh when i
heard it but pam got really offended oh
big boobs
drama coin nosy
you're typing big boobs i'm trying
everything trade big boobs with a z
that's
the password we're in all right wow yes
the important thing is this kept us
secure people
[Music]
boo
boo boo leslie no boo here comes the boo
all dressed and boo
boo lastly
boo
dude what are you doing i'm being
awesome boo boo leslie boop my friend i
don't think you understand what a bad
idea this is i don't think you
understand that i would have got a cut
of that new punch burger if she hadn't
screwed everything up so sorry guys this
wedding is cancelled cause the bride is
a b-hole hey check this out
stink bomb who knows what that does oh
stick bomb are you joking oh my god
where did you even get a stink bomb
amazon baby that's how you are looking
at a prime customer everybody two days
free shipping for this guy let's get
this party started with another one gang
no
ah it's terrible jerry you do the
wedding who cares come on man just go
home uh who's gonna make me
it's your wedding day
i'll handle this
here comes the bride
time to go sir no
hey get off me what the hell man don't
you touch me oh i'll give you that one
but if you do it again oh if i do what
again what kick your ass is that what
you like you want me to just pout
yay best wedding ever
you